hey youtubers is Charlie so the CW
confirmed Kitana for arrow season 3 and
her husband so they're gonna be like the
prequel version of team arrow so what
this is gonna be is a breakdown of the
katana character as well as a breakdown
of what's gonna be going on in those
honk-honk flashbacks because that's
where we're gonna meet those characters
hello to all the new people if you're
just finding me for the first time I do
arrow and flash stuff every week be sure
to subscribe to get it and yes I will be
doing videos for all the new comic book
shows that are coming in the fall so
Hong Kong arrow cave time
seriously though the new flashbacks will
be all about Oliver learning to take
what he learned on the island and apply
it to an urban area it's the in between
training that he gets before he comes
back to Starling in the pilot I know in
the pilot he had like a full-on super
beard but the way they tease it makes it
seem like he came and went from the
island several times like he didn't
spend all five years he was away on the
island so Devin Aoki is gonna be katana
you probably remember her best from Sin
City or Dead or Alive katanas husband is
named masayo Yamashiro he's being played
by Karl Yune you probably saw him in
Real Steel katana is a big comic book
character and Yamashiro is her husband
in the comics but he's a much smaller
character he actually did get
resurrected as a black lantern during
blackest night though that was pretty
cool so let's talk about the katana
character first they actually gave her
her own comic book about the same time
the gay vibe his own comic book and he's
a character on the flash so it's no
coincidence that katana is ending up on
arrow
she's also appeared in The Outsiders and
the birds of prey comics and the arrow
producers have said that we're gonna be
getting more birds of prey episodes in
season 3
Felicity being the Oracle character in
that situation her real name is sac su
and she's always been a good martial
artist even as a child growing up she
had two main suitors Masayo her future
husband and Takeo his brother I know two
brothers in love with the same woman
what could possibly go wrong
her parents were murdered mysteriously
and then she had twin girls yuki and
rico the brother Takeo
eventually came into possession of a
mythical blade called salt taker and
came to kill his brother in the process
of that Masayo and katanas twin
daughters died then she killed Takeo
with soul taker her husband's spirit
ended up being trapped in the blade and
then she took on the katana persona
after training with the master wonderful
family life I know but she's mostly been
featured over time in the outside her
comics but she's been part of the
Suicide Squad and the birds of prey
she also had a storyline that crossed
over with the geo force and Tara
characters in markovia
remember in arrow season 2 someone from
markovia tried to buy Merlin's prototype
Earthshaker device that wasn't like an
early lead that they were gonna use the
katana character it's just an example of
how they tie storylines across seasons
together her character also crossed over
with Lady Shiva several times she isn't
a villain she's more of an antagonist
but I know a lot of you really wanted
Shiva to come on the show and she still
can she's another League of Assassins
character that's just a really good foil
for katana and they could also totally
give the Lady Shiva persona to another
character with a different name just
like they did with ravager and Isabel
rochev based on the way arrow teases big
comic book character reveals I'm
guessing that katana won't be katana in
the Hong Kong flashbacks I do think
she's gonna be featured in present-day
there's no way you'd cast a character
that big and not let them be a badass in
modern day in like full-on superhero
garb and because her husband is alive in
the flashbacks I don't think she's gonna
have soul take her yet and whenever she
does have it in the future I don't think
they're gonna go on full-on supernatural
with it like it's not gonna turn into an
episode of Buffy the Vampire Slayer
they're probably just gonna call the
blade soul taker it would be funny if
the blade spoke with Misha Collins or
Jared Padalecki voice it would be nice
to know their souls were being used to
fight crime and kill bad guys in the DC
Universe so in the flashbacks katana and
her husband are gonna be Oliver's
handlers they're gonna work for Argus
and Amanda Waller they're also gonna
help train him while he starts his
business relationship with Amanda Waller
it's gonna be really interesting to see
that relationship develop so messiahs
gonna be like a cross between Diggle and
Yao Fei from the island he's gonna be
like his friend but he's also going to
help teach him how to be a warrior
katana will also be his friend the three
of them are basically going to be like
the proto version of team arrow all
superheroes either choose to build a
team around themselves or work alone
you know Batman is a good example of a
character that largely works alone even
though several versions of the Robin
character have come and gone Oliver on
the other hand is a team player
I think the Hong Kong flashbacks are
gonna show us why he thought it was
important to bring Felicity and Diggle
on in season 1 I'm really excited you
know if you haven't seen Stephen Amell
has been posting a ton of workout videos
to his Facebook page he's doing all this
parkour freerunning obstacle stuff the
area where he's working out is laid out
like a city so expect him to be
parkouring the
of Hong Kong they will be a comic-con
showing off a bunch of season 3 footage
I'm curious to see if they show off
flashback footage because they want to
introduce the new characters or if
they're gonna do something else I do
think that they will be teasing the new
arrowcave it's basically gonna be that
place where Felicity and Diggle found
Oliver hiding after Moira's funeral it
was a backup location he created in case
the original arrow cave under the
foundry got compromised and at the end
of season 2 the mirakuru soldiers
basically trashed it so more on the new
characters I've actually already done a
Blue Beetle video but basically they've
been using a lot of fake names in the
casting they've announced caste names
but essentially they used the Golden Age
name of the Blue Beetle so I think
they're gonna be using the Ted Kord
version of the character I know some of
you were bummed whenever Steve McQueen
said the Nightwing rumors were not true
but Nightwing was a huge part of the
outsiders just like katana so she does
get us one step closer to seeing a
Nightwing on the show and more on
katanas storylines that she had in comic
books in the new 52 universe she joined
the Suicide Squad to get Amanda Waller's
help and learning about her husband's
killers so when we see katana in
present-day arrow whatever she's got the
sword it's possible that they could use
some aspects of that storyline as a way
to bring her back into Oliver's life in
her spin-off comic whenever she was
tracking down her husband's killer she
found out they were connected to the
outsiders a criminal organization in the
new 52 comics as well as the new Green
Arrow's origin story
remember how Amanda Waller turned out to
be the one behind Edward Fyers on the
island what if they tied her husband's
murder and the outsiders to that same
organization
Waller's operation in Hong Kong she's
not a villain but she has been a Justice
League antagonist in the past one of the
things I really liked about arrow is the
way they tie everything together from
the flashbacks to present day they do a
really good job of setting up new
characters at the beginning of the
season
establishing relationships around Oliver
tearing those down then connecting them
back to a much bigger plot at the end so
you leave the season feeling like
everyone in the flashbacks and in the
present day is tied together by a single
villain I know Stephen Amell has been
teasing Batman villains coming on the
show but what if Amanda Waller turned
out to be the big villain of season 3
that would be a real twist but let me
know in the comments what do you think
about katana coming on arrow I cannot
wait to see her do some birds-of-prey
action with felicity and Huntress it's
gonna be so much fun so Stephen Amell
just announced he
coming to comic-con he's gonna be doing
a whole bunch of stuff way beyond
showing off new arrow footage so I'm
gonna be doing a bunch of bonus videos
for all that stuff as well as the flash
be sure to subscribe to get it all and
be sure to check out my Ronan the
accuser video that I posted yesterday
for guardians of the galaxy you can
click here to get it and click here to
learn about some of the other new
characters coming on arrow season 3
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives
you